Another thing Dr. Bright is not allowed to
do at the Foundation: Dr. Bright is strictly
prohibited from posting classified information
on 4chan.
In fact, he should know by now that he’s
not allowed to go on 4chan using Foundation
computers, but he’s definitely not allowed
to release classified information on the forum.
This includes but is not limited to: pictures
of containment cells and various anomalies,
such as pictures of SCP-682 with the caption
“Mondays, am I right?”
You are not right, this is not permitted.
This also includes information about any anomalies
contained on-site, as well as any Foundation
personnel.
If Dr. Gears is microwaving fish in the breakroom,
then that complaint needs to be handled through
official channels rather than an unregulated
internet forum.